what has happened in their citizens of the
reject Nation it is time for what everyone
is raving about being something amazing even
those who haven't seen it yet but after last
week's Cliffhanger I am very much excited for it
as I'm sure in theaters all hail the cowboy hat
like you don't put it in theaters unless it's
truly cinematic how are you MJ Tessler that's
a social media handle at MJ Tesla that's
me I'm really jazzed I like went back and
played the world Between Worlds episodes so
I'm just like so jazzed about this how are
you doing Greg I'm doing good it's been really
busy around here John ah great I've been I've
been soaking I don't have a good answer today
they use the force to leave a like today guys
and thank you to all I've been watching our
videos and continue to encourage us to be open
honest authentic and whatnot I also wanted to
say thank you to all who have been purchasing
some shirts over at the rejectnationshop.com
real rejects have launched the merch store
and you got all these awesome designs like
the soccer shirt that I'm wearing right now
now the last daddy sure which is a combination
of you know Mandalorian Patriot Pascal you get
the idea from looking at this image here this
one and then oh look at that one and that one
and there's even more and now I got my sister on
board to be like a family operation where she's
gonna be doing some more designs for us but
thank you guys to all I've been showing your
support it's one of the best ways to support
the channel anywho guys uh let's get into it
foreign
patreon page they could all be joining let's do it
make us wait it's fine do a
full sweep and report back Mom
[Music]
I said enough to help set them on their path
it's such a somber start I told them to stay
together oh poor guy don't blame yourself
I think they did such a great job on the
expression of his eyes they never listen
filoni directed this one right he's
got that handle on the emotion like
episode one was absolutely to us too yeah [Music]
oh look at this music in them chills
man I know Warrior okay it's Merrick
[Music]
done all the Clone War episodes
you look the same you look old
well that happens women aren't allowed to age you
lost a fight I don't remember trust me you lost
Palin skull yeah it's pretty [__]
cool so you do remember that's good why
still have a chance oh he's mentoring he got a
foot in the reality you got a foot in life tell
me what's going on I'm here to finish your
training yes she said in the first episode
he never finished my train and reminded us
of that one is never too old to learn snips
this is good this is very good what's
the lesson master live please [Laughter]
or die what exactly is he
I've heard that before oh wow
we're getting this [Music] oh
[Music]
cool [Music]
no just stay there final episode oh
gosh there's a lot of feelings right
now if that's the Aging too it looks
Exquisite I feel like I'm gonna enjoy
his appearance in this one episode
alone more than I did in Obi-Wan
I've got a thought Senator Organa says she can
only give us a cupboard for so long oh God if
we stay out here any longer without reporting in
people are going to start asking questions here's
the forest Jason we might benefit from people
asking a few more questions not if we don't have
any answers but mom there's something about the
water yeah yeah yeah you're right look music cute
pulls a broom out of nowhere Mom
listen I am no listen to the waves
General you said you wanted to be
a Jedi what are we listening for
it's obvious mom
servants and the waves the waves crashing
no the lightsabers oh wow dude you call that
early I didn't think it would happen this episode
great sound design
[Music] the emotional thrashing of waves
colliding with it too that's cool [Music]
literal chills
felony you son of a [__]
well done kid if you notice kanan's
pauldron on his side oh is it I didn't
catch it well we're doing it again Yang
you're with me in the ghost right away
she finally called it the ghost what am
I missing what just happened Jason has
was a Jedi
okay [Laughter] brilliant Carson
man of the people you know in uh in
the chest Ron species kids his age
they're called Skywalkers [Music]
oh man Anakin in his prime I
did not expect them to do this
there's that's fair looks like you don't
have enough to offer [Music] I haven't
taught you everything yet oh wow dang I call
that the youngling Slayer where are we going
the land of the mushroom where
are we going wait a second are we
sand I think sand hates that my arch nemesis
is [Music] it Geonosis step
back to the beginning whoa cool
oh no whoa [Music]
what a transition wow
is this for sure Geonosis no not 100 [Music]
but it's the uh yes it is this is an episode
of the Clone Wars yeah no kidding wow [Music]
you tell me wow wow wow jog your
memory correct that's your problem
oh where can I see Rex in the gate
this is insane stunts this is your training
wow this is what I wanted like so to be more about
yeah I mean actually about its Title Character
steam cameo no but we are gonna
get an age down tomorrow [Music]
oh then right off there's a Twilight yeah
yeah early on in the war that makes sense
when I said one of their first bat the first ones
right and it's still generation one armor too
go back you know who that is it tracks come
on snips I want to hear him speak it's Rex
come on speak is there a problem we lost so many
hating Christensen turning into Austin Butler
and I love it yeah okay this is so here for it
oh mannequin Skywalker it was my fault they
were following my orders I got them killed
come here she's always had a guilt complex his
Jedi it's our job to lead that doesn't mean we
don't make mistakes and our mistakes cost lives
that doesn't bother you of course it does that's
got a Bill Skarsgard thing about whatever else
this isn't what I trained for you must adjust
to the times uh-huh well Obi-Wan taught me
we were keepers of the peace to win this war
I have to teach you to be a soldier this is so
crazy all I'll have to teach my own Padawan one
day huh yes that's the lesson she needs to learn
do you even want a Padawan you didn't you know
teaching's not always cracked up let me tell
you I'm joking you're joking yeah a joke what
would you prefer tell me what do you want you
want me to be more serious it's so perfect I'm
teaching you how to lead how to survive and
to do that you're going to have to fight yes
I just love the full circle trajectory of how
this is the live action and there's Clone Wars
now this feels like an adaptation of Clone
Wars it's insane it really really is also Rex
say something yes please oh man this obscured
into the battlefield shots that he has yeah
Mr Tidings yeah oh geez a wedding is this all
just a some type of like conscious projection
like from her I I think it's a real lesson or
you think it's like actually Anakin if I figured
there's some damn that was like a poster you
see that yeah that was a poster shot right there
I mean the pergola are still out there that's
one way to get to our destination the new
Republic is only a short transmission away
I was surprised they changed their mind and
approved your mission so they never changed
their mind this mission is unauthorized
yeah some general I am just gonna need
help that's what you're supposed to do
you do things your way because you care this
is why people like you let's call some friends
hey Yang where are they people don't just
vanish Into Thin Air well no normally no
[__] I've seen this week
always especially with Lady Tano
tenacious tea so it was her master yeah
what was he like oh this is
great intense [Music] [Laughter]
chill a little older now no still yes damn
nice it's the Battle of Mandalore the siege
ah bad on those moves too relax yeah now this
is the end it's right during order 66 oh yes
a live action wrecks
she's so young
the arm cross
oh he was not there no he was doing something else
I don't know what this was the siege of Mandalore
we had parted Ways by now
it was a warrior now as I trained you to be
is that all what a great shot gun within
you will be everything I am oh For Better
or Worse just as I inherited Knowledge
from my master and he from his Legacy
Star Wars legacy but my part of that Legacy is
one of death and War but you're more than that
because I'm more than that oh it's feeling
bored as Taco you are more Anakin but
more powerful and dangerous than anyone
realized this is where you must resolve
d is that what this is about is that
what you called me here you've learned
nothing back to the beginning I gave you a
choice Boy live oh spread now huh or die man
Greatest Hits incorrect record
oh they're gonna find themselves in the in
the temple sequence during their last duel
oh boy
that is crazy I thought they slipped the breath
in there I was like when are we
gonna see this we'll get up again
this is great
oh my God
oh my God those eyes
[Music]
oh
strike me down
oh her eyes [Music] I choose to live
pallid
[Music]
I'm loving his performance
hey nice There's Hope for you yet [Music] we never
Gotta See Hayden Christensen be the live-actions
I'm very much in all that I feel like every time
he shows no panel he's like I gotta prove that
I can be a good performer in this role he's
got nothing to prove all he needed was a good
script and someone who can direct actors
oh it's about to be upside down water time
oh
stranger things oh soothing
foreign
[Music]
just lands right on her
oh my God it's Man of Steel
well done pilot
huge Kudos the team for Prosthetics that
can get wet like that yeah look sick shot
I love the Ethereal operatic music so much
well they actually gave Jason
a serviceable role instead of
just a cameo I wonder if now she can
commune with fourth ghost and I can
use the light again hope a mortise the father
said he was like more than all that right it's
it's heavily implied I think at this point that
he is that Anakin's the father she's the daughter
no we have not found her we were
hoping you could explain what happened
to see the makeup without her
yeah so now it's really well done
but I am aware it's makeup yeah for the first time
her and Jason could use the force to navigate
their way there that's what the chests do they
could follow the Pergo well that's what the
chests will use for sensitive youth to follow
the the difference the old way of hyperspace
travel oh I love her with a white look going on
oh my God she's become a soak of the white yeah
I rejoice she's got the Gandalf Journey he did
lightsabers fighting with I've been
in a Starship before Jedi Starship
we'll come along I'll show you the training
room I will train you you know how to build
a lightsaber yes can you teach me no
she might have left an impression on it
like a memory so we'll know what happened
use the force to see what happened
I love that works oh we're
actually gonna do it hell yes
yes
Force Echoes Cannon
oh it settles that her taking on the white as
well really sets her up to be the daughter if
that's what they're playing I mean she's gotta be
General we have a problem you always come in here
with bad news I'll deal with this you can work
out a way to find something how about a whale
[Music]
ring the neck that helmet used to
be on top of if I find you again
she couldn't say van again but
[Music] um
What secrets are they about to deliver for us do
you have evidence of Imperial Remnant activity or
of grand Admiral thrawn's return either love you
or you get on my nerves there's nothing more I can
do it's just tied up in a bureaucracy of Ruin
me the Senate oversight committee is going to
determine if your command should be permanently
suspended row you're going to need our testimony
to help you sorry I am not your only hope I don't
know how you score this but we're losing right now
I know how to follow Sabine
what is about to happen
all right all right I just love the way filoni
directs like the first episode in this one yeah
he just gets it yeah he really gets his
his directing voice really speaks to me
and the clouds and then how white
they are oh man [Music] oh wow wow
and it feels so gladly yeah so ethereal
that one hop on that one go inside
of it Jonah and the whale it
what a great throw back to the original
trilogy or is she gonna commune with him
let's go I'll give you 100 credits
do you want to buy some death sticks
wow
this is on a whole new level
hello there
wow are they mirroring shot of like the center
behind the frame showing her growth you are a
storyboard artist felony and whoever the
storyboard artist was an actual storyboard
you're gonna have to halt your approach to the
planet until I receive confirmation General has
indeed completed her mission Captain the reason
we are here is because there was no mission
above your pay grade I respectfully disagree
explain the nature of this Mission or I
will see to it that you are stripped of your
Rainbow okay but you're not gonna believe me
I'm really gonna talk to them that's the
idea they're going to do a cool handshake
it's just like the stories you told me how
the whales together in the bad guys far
far away it's great gentle Exposition
they'll take Ahsoka to where Ezra is
that's the stuff there is hope
she's really shining this episode
I think the episodes are at their best when it's
like just focus on a couple of characters sometime
this is such a great transformation
wow that's a scale Godless details Jesus wow
come on in [Music] will the ghost be
joining them hey hey get in there move us in
all right all right but you best come back inside
no no you'd want to look around wouldn't you
okay with it like how Ezra would do with animals
I know she's really expanding her
connection with the force yeah [Music]
Chomper
your son they know where Sabine was
taken I have no idea what no idea
hmm we'll just see where it goes oh she's
starting to really feel like as the Ahsoka
that we all kind of associated with that's better
than going nowhere whoa yeah oh my God we just
had to wait for the arc like patient viewers yep
crazy right Captain Gerard this is General sedula
yeah oh my God evasive
maneuvers it clear up their path
is the ghost in one of them
yeah no I don't think so
please let us see it please let us
see you travel [Music] wow wow wow
wow wow wow I had my doubts about space whales
and live action but man oh man the Pergo
wow sense of all [Music] same oh wow oh let's
go is she gonna just try to keep up sorry you
can't make the trip that's all right Jason's
too young to travel between galaxies season two
I'll find them I promise oh May the force
be with you force be with you and also
wow [Music] wow ah yes
just end it just end it well done well done
that was great beautifully done it was the
best episode easily sorry my heart is beating so
fast right now oh yeah I've got the I've got the
White Knuckles what's the first thing you want to
talk about buddy I got several topics here I'll
just check off whatever you start reading off
the performance and the chemistry and the magic
of Ahsoka and Anakin and live action yep like
red started there elevated elevated everything
um it was I feel like for Rosario Dawson this
was just the breakout episode where it was an
opportunity to like take an extraordinary
actor in the form of zero Dawson give her
an extraordinary acting partner what I thought
was a very beautiful a very succinct script um
there is a a magic between that relationship that
I think even fans that haven't watched Clone Wars
or Rebels will now have an understanding of why
we love those characters together so much I think
beyond that this reconciliation of this figure
that in so many ways shaped everything that she
is and shaped the world that she inherited and
that she's had to survive in to confront that
and to understand that as as a Padawan who
walked away from the Jedi Order she never
completed her training and to recognize that in
order to complete that training she needs to make
peace with her master and with herself because
undoubtedly she feels responsible for Vader's
fall and and and where I should say Anakin's
Fallen Invaders rise and there is just this
this feeling of for so long Star Wars has
been struggling to figure out what is it now
and this was the first time that the focus
and the clarity of what Dave filoni and a
whole group of amazing creatives at Star Wars
have been working towards these past few years
um and I think it's it's become clear to me uh
where it's going and I'm I'm so excited and I
also just you said it earlier uh and it's really
easy episode to episode to like get grumpy that
it's not there yet that it's not there yet but I
think the weight in this case really did make the
reward feel all the more special and weirdly
enough there was that moment when Ahsoka came
back the gandalf-like transformation which is just
brilliant uh when she's looking at sabine's helmet
I felt more chemistry between those characters
now that she's had this opportunity to go back and
I think remember what that Dynamic is supposed to
be and to understand that yeah her master wasn't
exactly a great teacher himself but that that
flawed nature of the Anakin Ahsoka relationship is
also what can make the ahsokan Sabine relationship
so special and I think that fear of her falling
like he fell uh has been holding her back so I'm
just I know I'm I'm like vomiting words right now
I'm just like emotionally moved at how much they
were able to capture in such a short time and the
actor that played young Ahsoka I thought captured
the spirit of Ashley Eckstein and the gravitas
of Rosario Dawson in in perfect fashion which
for like a young actor in Prosthetics in like
a crazy War sequence for five minutes is no small
feat um it was magic all right yeah okay what do
you want to talk about that's conversation oh
yeah sorry all those words I Echo them as well
I mean this did have a really really beautiful
I mean being that more outside viewer this
really had a resilience of energy on screen
that was really gripping and compelling and
I loved the way you know they bring back a
lot of characters and obviously we've seen
Anakin return for Obi-Wan and things like
that and you know sometimes it feels more
like it's designed to be exciting but it's not
necessarily designed to be meaningful whereas
here it felt like both it felt really kind of
natural that we would see Anakin in all these
different forms from across his timeline but we're
also seeing him through her perspective and I love
that reversal towards the end of their exchange
where they have the fight with him in Sith form
his eyes are all red he's got the scarring
and stuff like that and then after that you
know emotional breakthrough happens he sort of
resets and it's like an interesting way to look
at Anakin as a character because it's easy to look
at people and characters like this especially as
like a straight line into your descent you know
into evil whereas you know this is kind of a I
thought it was a really great lesson to be learned
from teacher to student that it is like yeah it's
not just about like how I turned out it's about
the totality of what I have given you and even my
end is a bit of teaching for you you know and is a
Telltale sign that you could perhaps avoid in the
future instead of giving in telling to the fear of
that and losing yourself to the dark side so yeah
yeah like that is felt like a very it felt like it
earned its gravitas I was like effortlessly ripped
by that and then yeah traversing these different
specific battle moments and stuff like that like
these are the moments that then make me go like
yeah I would love to dive further into these
things you know whereas previous episodes have
had references where I'm like yeah you know it's
fine yeah um so yeah yeah I think that what
Hayden Christensen brought here was really
I think I was in awe of it because I didn't
exactly know what they were going to be doing with
him and I think they managed to do something that
was multi-layered and also open to interpretation
I don't think you can it is a conversation I would
like to actually have because there's this whole
you can't just I don't know sometimes they have
a line here or there that's like here was Kanan
he was a Jedi all right cool there's this whole
thing about mortis and father son and daughter
that I don't know how you can just like throw
out a line to explain that to General audiences
because that's a whole new can of force worms
that you just can't really uh just throw out
there and expect people to just latch at you
right away right and I think though if you are
aware of that that you can't interpret okay maybe
Anakin is this um oh I mean you know this is her
caught between life and death right now this
is like a Purgatory ass World Between Worlds
can be a representation a Purgatory it can be a
representation of that uh because you know like
she wakes up in the water and she's choosing
to live so it could just be something simple as
that and this is a manifestation of going through
her subconscious and facing things and uh these
these certain traumatic memories and trying to
learn from those lessons as well and revisit
because a lot of it is her revisiting stuff
right with Anakin so what I was in awe of was
how it managed to be so multi-layered with okay
you can interpret Anakin on a multiple multiple
layers he could be the father for mortis if you're
familiar with that he could be Force ghost Anakin
working his way through the because because of
what Clone Wars described on that mortis Arc
he wouldn't be your typical Force ghost plain
and simple he just wouldn't be that guy yeah that
typical one shows up and then the most the best
part about it to me though is Hayden Christensen
we've never got to see him do live action mentor
of the relationship with Ahsoka and that is the
heart of Clone Wars that is the heart of why we
loved Ahsoka was that friendship that developed
between them and it was what was blowing my mind
I guess was who played him in Clone Wars do you
remember uh I don't remember who played him
oh God I'm so embarrassed it was not hating
Christians okay yeah it was not hating Christians
oh this is going to stress me and while while
there were aspects that were supposed to remind
you of Hayden Christensen that actor really did
his own thing and the writing really did its own
thing as well that helped fill in a certain type
of Gap but we never got to see Hayden Christensen
be that version that made many of us love Anakin
that much more was his interpretation on that
was that interpretation on the show and we got
to see that relationship brought to life in these
Dynamics and sort of this like ethereal ponderous
sort of way uh but we still got to see those
interactions so when he's saying [__] like
Snips when he's actually saying it's not
just like Easter egg lines it feels like
I'm watching The Animated relationship it's
like this weird full circle trajectory where
first the live action Hayden Christensen cast
okay we're gonna draw him in the likeness of him
he's gonna do some of his own inspiration but
really do his own thing and I felt like Hayden
Christensen watched the animated show oh of course
and then adopted a lot of that because his acting
was not I mean like when you see him in Obi-Wan
he did a good job but I didn't really feel like
we got too much new other than more exploration
of him being mad you know being rageful and hurt
this was like oh man they're doing the
animated relationship and I thought that
was that was the part that I because even
if you haven't seen the animated version
for Live Action you have not seen this side of
Anakin before yeah and and so I think and it's
the soft side that makes his descent all the more
that's what makes a heartbreak yeah yeah there was
something that I don't want to get lost in in
all like there was like so much in this episode
there was a spirituality with the force that
I haven't felt in a long long time uh and part
of the magic is is kind of in what Anakin was
saying about the thread of Master and Apprentice
and this idea of Anakin's time as a Jedi will
forever be marked by the fact that he was a
Jedi who had to become a general who fought in
war who fell and you have each of these I mean
like I know I like the other the other episodes
like name them all but you have Anakin to Obi-Wan
Obi-Wan who who offers so much and from Obi-Wan
you have Qui-Gon who offers so much for quargon
you have Count Dooku who offers so much and
and I love that eventually you get to Rey who
gets it all yeah so but it is the force is this
thread it's it's not the individual of this of
any of the Jedi it's it's what they pass down
to each other their failures their successes
their hopes their dreams their fears their
nightmares all of those things collectively
create this like beautiful beautiful thread
and I think Ahsoka kind of coming to terms with
he who the times that you live in while they
Define your actions don't necessarily to find
you it gives you an opportunity to to forge
yourself into something and and she's kind
of been stuck in this kind of permanent
state of War she was raised into this and
um I think for Ahsoka to like finally reconcile
and spiritually come to terms with it I mean it's
like very much and I know like we all instantly
like Gandalf Gandalf but like a very similar
these like Gandalf after he fell uh uh you know
uh with the battle Rock like the amount of time
like it didn't seem like a lot like it was
really quick but it also felt like forever
and he came back and and there was this like in
understanding and at peace with you know in his
case theatari but in ahsoka's case I think she's
really reconnected with the force in the most uh
authentic of ways and I know everyone was grumpy
when Ahsoka didn't show up uh like she did in
Rebels with the the whole Gandalf the White get up
at the in the finale I think this really clarified
for us I think this because on episode two I
know they're like for us I think when we first
saw it we thought they were just paying homage
to the ending of rebels in episode two but this
um that everyone else was saying that no that
this is recontextualizing they're redoing it
and this only further drove that home yeah well I
I think it was I think Dave filonian is infinite
Brilliance realized that this would be an arc
for Ahsoka that she needed to go on throughout
the course of the show yeah and to begin her
there would do an injustice to her and yeah I
mean it was it was apparent that that was one of
the seeds they were planting and I think where the
dichotomy that uh as a viewer I was running into
was when it came to information displacement focus
and the emotion underneath all that like I always
I understood everything that happened in episode
four and I overall liked episode four I just was
having a difficult time connecting emotionally
with it the way how apparently the rest of the
world did uh whoops I was having a difficult time
connecting with that yeah and and I feel like
okay there's something specifically about the
way filoni himself directs where I mean it makes
sense to me I mean it's it's his show even with
so much time with these characters I mean nobody
intimately understands Ahsoka and Sabine better
than Dave filoni well even when he's the one
not directing he still gets all the credit and
he gets all the criticism too because they're all
written by him yeah the director is essentially
honor whoever the other director is the other
ones that most of the times that they're just
honoring trying to bring Dave filoni's Vision to
life yeah and then you feel the full vision and
scope of this because there's there's perhaps
maybe in terms of the storytelling of ahsoka's
Arc here there's a part of me that's like oh
you know it would have been cool to have like
just a little bit more just a conversation
with it between uh Ahsoka and Anna you just
want to look like cherry on top conversation
maybe that's kind of a maybe department for me
however I think what he ex excelled at here
was doing stuff visually tonally and knowing
how to communicate all that of what's going on
admittedly on a gorgeous surface but underneath
the surface of what's going on that you can
actually understand oh I get the trajectory
that Ahsoka is going on because it seemed like
that was the art that she was having ultimately
go down this problem this resistance with Sabine
having to train her and then her expressing some
you know uh uh Anakin didn't finish training me
and um yeah there is a bit of information I I
can't help but wonder about the people though
that are not familiar with Clone Wars I can't
help them I feel like they did such a good job
at giving that part of the audience a glance
and an understanding of the dynamic that being
said why would she but felony like I don't know
what I'm getting at is I understand why she
would blame herself yeah for Anakin's descent
and if you didn't watch Clone Wars would you
would you get why she wouldn't why she would
blame herself not yet but I don't I don't I
don't I don't think we're done yet with that
I do think something that just kind of like
hit me like a brick while you were talking
Dave filoni's selection of Mandalore was brilliant
yeah because in the siege of Mandalore you ready
for some poetry in the siege of Mandalore he
wasn't there yeah when she needed him and when
he needed her most yeah and when sabine's family
desperately needed her on manual Ahsoka wasn't
there for Sabine and Sabine apparently wasn't
there for a second that's true so you know I think
um the the real question is will we continue
through the progression of of you know the series
see Ahsoka and Anakin continue that training
like I caught the sense tonality wise that
there's still lessons to be learned I think
to your point about like the conversation
as the cherry on top if they had just had a
conversation instead of doing that powerful
visual storytelling it would have felt great
sure but it wouldn't have been as earned as
as now if Anakin were to commune with her if she
would commune with Anakin or however it you know
um I meant like everything they did and also well
that's what I'm saying I think I think we're gonna
get I hope so anyway I think we're gonna get
a a version of that and in the same way of
uh when when Yoda tells Obi-Wan you know you're
going to commune with your old master and learn
how to part of me kind of feels like Anakin's
gonna teach Ahsoka not just that but also
something that goes beyond just like being a force
ghost yeah and uh I wanted quickly because what I
what I thought was really cool because I was gonna
spend so much time on Anakin and everything what
I really loved too was I I did have a thought go
okay is this gonna dip now that we're done with
Anakin's part of the story and it didn't uh it
remained great and I want to talk about Hera what
I think is really cool of what they've done with
Hera for you guys who are not familiar yeah they
explained who Kanan was but that was like the
love story of of rebels between Kanan and Hera
and you know on Kanan kanan's death is one of the
like is one of the most heartbreaking parts of
watching Rebels it is a it is a Monumental moment
and it gets etched into your memory forever once
you experience it basically and Hera was privy for
that moment and shortly before that saying like I
love you and everything wow she was pregnant
yeah pregnant and pregnant at all right and
um he dies in such a tragic way without her
getting to say goodbye and what I think is
they're doing so well here with the depiction of
Jason who wants to be a Jedi is clearly shaping
up to be like I want to go more down my father's
path right like you know all these things is that
you they're doing such a great job of that even
though she didn't get to have that goodbye Kanan
gets to live on through Jason and keeping that
connection and that relationship evolving and what
they're developing with Jason which a lot of time
I feel like I would not actually there's like this
depiction or Jason I'm like I feel like in other
in some kind of there's some alternate execution
of this and I would not enjoy but but I'm really I
really enjoyed it yeah like I thought it was again
it all comes down to execution and tone for
me and and then of course that deeper context
of understanding what Jason is representing
and and Hera as well like the I really loved
um I got because like there were people who
were saying that they thought you're Mary
Elizabeth Winstead's performance episode
four was like the best she's done and
there were people who are saying that and I I
don't agree with that I loved her performance
here though in this episode she really really
found it and not just found it but captured
like the Nuance of like I always thought hero
was such an interesting character like she is
in so many ways a lot bigger of a deal than like
uh Rebels let her be like in my like like because
we're always so focused on the Jedi side of
things we forget like she's like the daughter
of this like crazy like Rebel leader um you know
fought during the Clone Wars she literally helps
build the rebellion in its infancy she's so
complex and she constantly juggles this like
she has to put it all out there and be so
vulnerable and I feel like we really got to see
that and I can only imagine and I and I I felt it
in this episode both the pride and the fear that
comes with your child taking after his father who
is a Jedi now I'll tell you what I'm excited for
I want to flash forward and see Freddie Prince Jr
play because he did such an amazing yeah it'd be
so cool to you know but it's It's Curious like
where is that gonna go like are we gonna see
that character's future I hope he's not at the
Jedi Temple when kylo has his meltdown like I
hope he is that'd be hilarious I hope that's the
end of that's the ending post credits yeah yeah
yeah I want you to meet someone this is to kylo
all right I do I do think what should be noted
for like expanded universe fans um there is
Jason solo and that whole story arc like obviously
Dave filoni has a love for the expanded universe
and stuff that got cut out you know when when
Disney bought the the property um I'm curious if
they're gonna try to pursue some of those story
Arts um which would make sense because thrawn's
involved and you know we'll see we'll see um the
the Pergo the Pergo we got to talk about that uh
I mean we all saw that coming right yeah but
but the way we got there felt it didn't land
in a perfunctory or rote way it didn't just seem
like they had to do it that way like they've been
setting that up how disappointing would it be if
we didn't do it all that set up with the purple
this is the whole [__] time and we never decide
yeah what do we travel via through them you know
can you imagine if we never did that but they
earned it that way I I mean I loved the whole
um I love the whole idea that she had to get more
in tune with herself but in chance getting more
in tune with the force which is what allows
her to connect with the Pergo to be able to
travel like literally be like hey can you fly
me you know because they were just hybrid they
were just like floating around and she needed
to communicate with them like I need you to
take me and the fact that she was able to do
it uh that way instead of hopping like like uh
um what's it called like when you they did it like
they've done it in rubble already like land on to
them oh yeah yeah yeah yeah instead of just like
hot day no well it's getting a train it was part
of this like continued theme of the episode where
we're diving into a different side of the force
we're we're really like the force Echoes when she
was remembering what like the conversation was was
being like which you've seen in like Fallen
ordering yeah well that's exactly like we've
we've seen it in other places but we've never seen
it live action we've never seen it canonically uh
uh and I think it's getting to the spirituality
of this character which is something that I
always loved about Ezra's character and
something that they explored with him
um that's on our thing too is the most Soca
focused episode and I think that's why I loved
it the most too well it needed this was just so
focused I I stand by like the flashback sequences
to the Clone Wars I think really were like the
perfect demonstration of why it would have been
really nice to see at least like a moment of uh
Ahsoka and Sabine while their relationship was
good like like I know it's heavily implied and
that's like the one thing that I I'm and yeah
and I know that we'll see what it will be by the
end of this and I'm sure it will be amazing I just
wish I don't think it's I don't feel like it's
I love this episode I'm not gonna sit here and
be like it's absolved of the other things that
I am concerned about though like this like I I'm
still not that connected to the Sabine and Ahsoka
relationship yeah as much as I would like to be I
understand the context we can obviously break
it down be like yeah this this poetry runs but
like we can do all that um it's more about what is
the show doing to communicate the relationship on
screen and how much of a feeling am I generating
from this you know so that and that is such a main
thrust of this show so yeah but I know you wanted
to say something well no I mean this doesn't yeah
absolve some of the gripes from previous episodes
but this did feel like the most fully realized
and like it managed to draw out a proper balance
between the deliberate Pace they've been going
for but all also with having it feel like a good
amount of things are developing and even though
things happen gradually they seem to happen with
that sort of magical sense of design around the
periphery where you can have a growth of character
within Ahsoka that feels like it makes sense with
everything that came before but it also feels
quite rewarding when it's like oh yeah like
part way through when she comes back out and she's
in the white she's got a whole other enchantment
to her personality there's just like a growth of
that and even the thing with the Pergo has this
like spiritual feeling quality and everything in
the world Between Worlds has its spiritual quality
to it even with Jason listening to the waves the
sensory qualities the elemental like this did a
good job for me of putting you wherever it was
putting you in a very lucid way much more than
the previous ones have done where I've been kind
of looking at an arms distance at some interesting
stuff and waiting for it to really like hook into
my spirit so to speak and this uh managed to do
that in understated ways you know most heavily
stated with Ahsoka and Anakin and all that but
in understated ways with kind of everybody and
this was the first time it felt like even though
you know people were on different missions and
story lines and stuff like this does now feel
like an ensemble here in this moment and uh and
yeah like the the journey feels like there is both
excitement Adventure hope and Peril on the horizon
and it just feels like you can extrapolate so much
more out of it than just kind of sitting and going
okay cool a couple things happened but I don't
feel you know as moved connected or otherwise
like this managed to like feel like sequentially
naturally the next episode and yet also feel like
it has all the things that have been messing up
until now um and lastly uh great Thai super fights
yeah terrifies for great yeah um hurricane back to
the prequels um and the way they did that and I
I really I like these lightsaber fights the way
they were shot more than again like I liked the
last episode I just wasn't in love with it like
everyone else and people were really in love with
those lightsaber fights and I thought they were
good but I I feel like this was an ex I thought
this was better I'll just say that like I'm not
interested I think that episode five versus four
but I thought this was a really sharply executed
I think part of it's the emotion that goes into
that's exactly like that's exactly you know I
two of them yeah no the two of them just
have such like there is history and with
every strike of the blade you can feel it
um you know whereas with like Bailey it was
beautiful I mean he's doing this like European
medieval style and ahsoka's doing this you know
samurai-esque that's cool mood and all yeah yeah
it's cool but well I'm super this was evocative
not just Moody yeah well I I think uh ideally
we'll get the best of both worlds let's hope so
um either way I'm so excited hey what did y'all
think I feel like the internet's a buzz right
now uh thanks for keeping us on track no
but no I'm I'm serious I want to know that
I really appreciate and I know last week we got
some heat [Music] I don't know I love it people
brought up some really great things next weekend
suck and I'll be honest about it if it sucks
it was it was magic uh and you know what I thought
this was great this is magical and this this is
um this is what happens with patients and
when you give creatives the power to do
what they do yeah you were ending this so
leaves leave the force all right behind you
we gotta go I gotta edit man use the force
to leave a like And subscribe all right bye
[Music]